shake spirit shakes you know I like say
he's an explorer he's a scientist first
of all he's always going into uncharted
territory he steeled stories from
everybody but what he does or those
stories is clearly an actor his
imagination in his will and its
intelligence and its observation i think
is a very very close observer of people
with their wonderful writers but they'll
never be another change but also never
be another safe because there will never
be a sort of renaissance of discovering
the classical world or discovering the
use of language as it was then we'll
have all kinds of technological
Renaissance asst but we probably won't
have a language Renaissance ever again
because language has quote been
discovered and it's not new north of
anything we have to learn to be better
at it and use it more interestingly than
we do now